nancy pelosi setting off a new wave of
fury and threats from china after
touching down in taiwan beijing warning
that the trip could have serious
consequences pelosi getting an escort
from taiwan's air force while flying in
earlier today the u.s and taiwan on high
alert with four american warships
positioned off the east side of the
island
china reportedly set to respond with
live fire military drills surrounding
taiwan and new video shows chinese tanks
rolling on its coastline
beijing piling on with the threats and
saying america will pay
we will take whatever we can
to
respond
and to protect to safeguard our
sovereignty territory integrity and our
response will be
very far strong
and forceful
pelosi not backing away from this
face-off with china but the white house
is refusing to take a firm stance about
the trip watch
nothing's changed about our one china
policy nothing's changed about our
support to taiwan and their self-defense
and the speaker has a right to travel
she is the speaker of the house she is a
member of congress members of congress
of both parties as you know have
traveled to taiwan even just this year
now it's an independent branch of
government we gave her advice and
counsel we gave her context and
information obviously as is typical we
are helping with her transportation but
this is a decision that only she can
make and we support and respect that
decision republicans are calling out the
white house for showing weakness and
putting pelosi in a bad spot
this administration seems to be afraid
at every step of the way of provoking
our adversaries if you've seen what's
happened in ukraine they've consistently
signaled that what we're not going to do
out of fear of provoking putin the same
thing i think is true here we're so
risk-averse we're afraid of provoking
the chinese communist party we put
ourselves in a straitjacket joe biden
elevated this to defcon 1 last month
he should have never leaked it to the
public that nancy pelosi was going to go
to taiwan to try to pressure not to go
he shouldn't have said the military
didn't want her to go the administration
should not pressure her not to go we
cannot allow the chinese communists to
dictate where american citizens can
travel and what we can do around the
world especially our elected leaders
greg goodfield where do you stand on the
pelosi taiwan situation oh man this is
so interesting i have to say war with
china
as well as russia was not on my bingo
card
i mean we need to look back at all those
big thick books written by all the
important people from the brookings
institution or where's francis fukuyama
where are all the people that said this
was going to be great and it's all
falling apart i go back to 2017 it was a
terrible time for this world because of
all those trump tweets right the
punishing relentless psychological
torture that he caused thank god that's
gone now we just have inflation a cold
war a hot war uh raging crime wave north
korea is even back so thank god
no tweets
but to your point what is this trip
trying to prove is it worth the cost is
it a practical move or is it a costly
virtue signal i find my problem is i
find myself agreeing with people i don't
trust or disagreeing with people i trust
it's incredibly confusing which is why
this is a great story because it's
flipping everybody around if i say the
trip is bad i agree with the new york
times if i say the trip is good i agree
with drudge i'm the real victim so i'm
thinking i agree with mitt
and trump because it's rare that they're
on the same side
they're saying this is an expensive trip
and it's not worth it you don't want
world war three to be started by nancy
pelosi a congresswoman from california
into her ninth decade with a face
tighter than a snare drum i guess though
you know we you know like to uh what
they what the congressman was saying you
know why heed
china's warning when we didn't even heed
russia's warning about nato right and
that worked out splendid
what is china going to do now jessica
they've made a lot of threats they
didn't carry through with those threats
but now they say more is coming
i guess we wait and see and we're as
prepared as we can be and it seems like
they were for everything they've gotten
so far obviously they
executed a few cyber attacks on
taiwanese government sites um but so far
these are all things that we can bear in
in support of taiwan i don't think that
we're regretting the decision right now
the thing that i find most interesting
about what's gone on is what senator
cotton was saying that the biden
administration were the ones that leaked
the details of this because when it
first started coming on the press i said
on air who leaked this
because it's
official policy that nancy pelosi's
whereabouts are not known until she just
shows up in a photo op in acts place and
she's
third in line
right and
if it was the administration that's an
incredibly dangerous thing to do to just
get your way over visit
um
you could have just called her and maybe
he talked her down from doing this or
asked for different timing
and
that's a game that i don't think that
they should have played if that is
what they did but i do unlike greg well
i mean the the upside down stuff it is
fun but it is nice to see
generally a pretty unified front in
terms of you have that uh
letter come out 45 republicans signing
in support of her including mcconnell
saying this is you know what we should
be doing and standing with our taiwanese
allies and and i do like to see that
that's kind of a bold move to leak the
trip
for nancy pelosi from the bite
administration why do you think they
would do that to box her in absolutely
and you know to assert control over her
and to show her that she's not the one
who sets the agenda certainly not the
foreign policy agenda of this
administration which they've done a
horrible job of and you know it's like i
agree with greg i think that there
should be more disruptors there there
should be more uh turning the apple cart
upside down and seeing where the apples
roll because i don't think the chaos and
disruption are the same thing as being
provocative she's not necessarily
provoking war what she's doing is being
a little bit unpredictable but still
standing up for freedom and people who
are standing up for freedom especially
internationally they're few and far
between there are way too many lebron
james and way too few and his cantor
freedoms
that is true katie do you agree with
that i do agree with that i also think
it's important to talk about the fact
that we are not causing this conflict
the united states china
is causing this conflict they are the
ones who are acting irrationally they're
the ones making the threats it is not
uncommon for politicians from the united
states to go to taiwan they're an
independent country we have a hundred
billion dollar trade agreement with them
it is totally normal for the speaker of
the house to go to taiwan to visit with
their leaders um so
xi jinping is supposed to be anointed
emperor for life basically in the next
couple of months i think a lot of the
posturing here has to do with that and
also we are not prepared for a long-term
fight with china china is in all of our
institutions they were in our confucius
institutes there are professors and
universities across the country are
being paid to give china our
intellectual property
they own still a lot of our ppe
production which we saw during the
pandemic they used as a weapon against
us and the rest of the world after
causing the pandemic
we have not done enough to take our
supply chains out of that country and so
you know china is has imp put itself in
u.s politicians and u.s companies and we
are not prepared for a long-term
conflict and this taiwan situation is a
very small taste of what china plans to
do in the future in terms of making
demands and threats and as long as we
are reliant on them it's going to be a
problem for us is this her swan song
greg is she going to retire after they
lose the house and is this her doing a
little far east swing as the big
diplomat and burnishing her credentials
as a big china hawk that's a terrible
reason to do this then right i'm still
trying to opposition to a lot of stuff
yeah yeah for pr but uh i am actually i
was thinking about what kennedy said
when she brought up lebron james it is
kind of interesting when you saw those
brave thought leaders screaming bloody
murdy murder about the saudis and the
golf tournament but where are they on
china
where are you can you weigh in on this i
mean all you all you nba players has
anybody asked lebron about this lately i
mean
how many people are still i mean we keep
talking about decoupling and we're and i
don't know are we decoupling i don't
think we're decoupling at all
it doesn't sound that much fun no it's
like witness control and chris martin
are still married yes yes exactly living
in the same place very messy we are
consciously decoupling from china it's
just taking a very long time yes hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now